SHE FACES NINE COUNTS OF WIRE
FRAUD AND TWO COUNTS OF
CONSPIRACY TO COMMIT WIRE FRAUD.
CLOSING ARGUMENTS SCHEDULED FOR
NEXT WEEK.
>>> IT'S A PART OF AMERICAN REAL
ESTATE MORAL AND RACIST.
IT IS CALLED WHITEWASHING.
AFRICAN AMERICANS MAY GET A
HIGHER VALUE ON THEIR PROPERTY
WHEN THEY REMOVE THEMSELVES
ENTIRELY FROM THE SELLING
PROCESS.
JOE JOHNS WITH MORE ON WHAT
HAPPENED TO ONE COUPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
>> Reporter: TENISHA AND PAUL
AUSTIN BOUGHT THEIR HOME IN THE
MARIN CITY OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN 2016.
IT CAME WITH A COVETED VIEW OF
THE BAY BUT A LONG TO-DO LIST.
>> IT NEEDED A LOT OF WORK, BUT
WE WERE UP TO THE TASK.
>> Reporter: THEY ADDED A DECK,
A GAS FIREPLACE, AND ADDITIONAL
LIVING SPACE.
IN JANUARY OF 2020, WITH THE
BUILDOUT ALMOST FINISHED, THEY
DECIDED TO REFINANCE AND TAKE
SOME CASH OUT OF THE PROPERTY.
THEY GOT AN APPRAISAL.
>> IT WAS RIGHT BEFORE COVID
HIT.
SO THE RATES WERE EXTREMELY LOW.
SO WE WERE TRYING TO REFINANCE
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE LOW
RATES.
>> Reporter: TO THEIR SURPRISE,
THE APPRAISER WROTE THAT THE
HOUSE WAS ONLY WORTH 995,000
DOLLARS.
>> WE WERE SICK, SICK TO OUR
STOMACHS.
WE WERE UPSET, ANGERED.
>> I WAS DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE,
ONE, I KNEW THE HOUSE WAS WORTH
MORE THAN THAT.
SECONDLY, WE NEEDED THE HOUSE TO
APPRAISE FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT IN
ORDER FOR US TO BE ABLE TO PULL
OUT THE CAPITAL IN IT.
AND WHEN IT DIDN'T COME IN AT
THAT, IT WAS DEVASTATING.
>> Reporter: THEY SUSPECTED THAT
THE SEEMING LOW-BALL EVALUATION
FROM AN APPRAISER WHO HAPPENED
TO BE A WHITE WOMAN, MAY HAVE
HAD SOMETHING TO DO WITH THEIR
RACE OR THEIR LOCATION, OR BOTH.
MARIN CITY HAS A SIZABLE AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATION, UNLIKE
MARIN COUNTY, WHICH IS MOSTLY
WHITE.
>> SHE CONSIDERED US MORE IN THE
CITY AND DEVALUED OUR HOME.
.
>> AND SAW A BLACKFACE.
>> Reporter: SO THEY DECIDED TO
PUT THEIR SUSPICIONS TO A TEST.
THEY REQUESTED YET ANOTHER
APPRAISAL AND GOT A FEMALE
FRIEND, WHO WAS WHITE, TO COME
TO THE HOUSE TO MEET THE
APPRAISER TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE
THIS WAS HER HOUSE.
>> I CONTACTED HER AND I SAID WE
HAVE ANOTHER -- OUR APPRAISAL
CAME IN LOW.
WE HAVE A NEW APPRAISER COMING.
CAN YOU COME AND BE ME.
>> Reporter: BUT THAT'S NOT ALL
THEY DID.
THEY REMOVED ANY EVIDENCE THAT
BLACK PEOPLE EVEN LIVED THERE, A
PROCESS CALLED WHITEWASHING.
>> WE TOOK DOWN EVERYTHING THAT
THIS HOME BELONGED TO US.
>> OR TO AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILY.
>> ART, PICTURES.
>> EVEN MY HAIR PRODUCTS, I PUT
THEM AWAY SO THAT SOMEONE
WOULDN'T BE TIPPED OFF BY THEM.
>> Reporter: A DIFFERENT
APPRAISER, ALSO A WHITE WOMAN
WHO VISITED THE HOUSE IN
FEBRUARY OF 2020, CAME BACK WITH
A VALUATION OF MORE THAN $1.4
MILLION, AN APPRAISAL 49% HIGHER
THAN THE PREVIOUS ONE.
IN DOLLARS, THAT'S A $487,500
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWO
APPRAISALS THAT CAME ABOUT THREE
WEEKS APART.
IN FEDERAL COURT, THE AUSTINS
HAVE SUED THE A FRASER, GENNETT
MILLER, WHO GAVE THEM THE LOWER
ESTIMATE, ALLEGING HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION.
MILLER DID NOT RESPOND TO
SEVERAL REQUESTS TO GRANT US AN
INTERVIEW OR PUT US IN CONTACT
WITH HER LAWYER.
DEVALUING HOME PRICE IS STARTING
TO ATTRACT MORE ATTENTION IN
WASHINGTON.
IT'S NOT ALWAYS ABOUT MILLION
DOLLAR HOMES.
ANDRE PERRY WRITES ABOUT IT.
>> WE FOUND HOMES IN BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS ARE UNDERPRICED BY
23%, ABOUT 48,000 CUMULATIVELY.
THERE'S $156 BILLION IN LOSS
EQUITY IN BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS.
$156 BILLION.
>> Reporter: AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THE ISSUE RAISED BY STORIES
LIKE THIS IS ABOUT LOSS OF
WEALTH IN BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES.
IF YOU OWN PROPERTY AND YOU WANT
TO TAKE CASH OUT TO REMODEL,
SEND A KID TO COLLEGE, PAY BILLS
OR INVEST IN THE STOCK MARKET, A
LOW APPRAISAL OF YOUR PROPERTY
CAN BE A LIFE-CHANGING EVENT.
BUT THIS MAY BE AN ISSUE WHOSE
TIME HAS ALMOST COME.
THE PAST JUNE, BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED A TASK
FORCE TO START LOOKING INTO THE
PROBLEM.
JOHN AND BRIANNA.
.
>> JOE JOHNS, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
>> THAT IS SUCH A VIVID EXAMPLE.
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
AND JOE'S RIGHT.
IT'S A LIFE-CHANGING EXPERIENCE.
FIRST OF ALL, YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT MORALLY LIFE CHANGING
BECAUSE YOU THINK THE SYSTEM IS
STACKED AGAINST YOU.
FINANCIALLY.
IT'S YOUR LIFE SAVINGS.
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE THAT LASTS
FOREVER.
>> THERE IS MORE OF A FOCUS ON